[Music]
your IT department is under tremendous
pressure marketing wants to give
customers real-time responses to web
enquiries order fulfillment wants
inventory levels updated every 30
seconds your sales force wants
omni-channel access to their data
and some groups are going rogue setting
up shadow IT departments finance now has
a team to create their own apps and the
development team has set up a new test
site with a non-compliant cloud vendor
how can a conscientious IT Director
maintain control while ensuring security
and quick response IBM can guide you
with a clear comprehensive
proven approach to cloud adoption and
transformation our approach is the
result of helping many clients over many
years and harness their requirements and
empower their transformation our
extensive experience led us to cultivate
seven key dimensions that drive
successful cloud adoption culture and
organization architecture and technology
security and compliance emerging
innovation spaces methodology service
management and operations and governance
we have the tools and techniques to help
you analyze your current position and
recommend the changes you need to arrive
at your goals together will create an
actionable roadmap that you can execute
on your own timeline
or we'll help you rapidly adopt cloud
using many of our best practices and
accomplished specialists when you choose
IBM you'll work with vendor agnostic
open platform integration experts and
multi cloud and hybrid transformations
it's your journey IBM can help you get
to where you want to go
you